I want to talk to you about how to build
and rebuild trust because it's my belief
that Trust is the foundation for
everything we do and that if we can
learn to trust one another more we can
have unprecedented human progress
but what if Trust is broken what if your
CEO is caught on video disparaging an
employee what if your employees
experience a culture of bias exclusion
and worse what if there's a data breach
and it feels an awful lot like a
cover-up than seriously addressing it
and most tragically what if a
technological fail leads to the loss of
human life if I was giving this talk six
months ago I would have been wearing an
uber t-shirt I'm a Harvard Business
School professor but I was super
attracted to going to an organization
that was metaphorically and perhaps
quite literally on fire
I had read everything that was written
in the newspaper and that was precisely
what drew me to the organization this
was an organization that had lost trust
with every constituent that mattered but
there's a word about me that I should
share my favorite trait is redemption I
believe that there is a better version
of us around every corner and I have
seen firsthand how organizations and
communities and individuals change at
breathtaking speed I went to over with
the hopes of a turnaround there could
give license to the rest of us who might
have narrower versions of their
challenges
but when I got to over I made a really
big mistake I publicly committed to
wearing an uber t-shirt every day until
every other employee was wearing an uber
t-shirt I had clearly not thought that
through it was 250 days of wearing an
uber t-shirt now I am liberated from
that commitment as I am back at HBS and
what I'd like to do is share with you
how far I have taken that liberty which
it's baby steps but I would just say I'm
on my way now
trust if we're gonna rebuild it we have
to understand its component parts the
component parts of trust are super well
understood there's three things about
trust if you sense that I am being
authentic you are much more likely to
trust me if you sense that I have real
rigor in my logic you are far more
likely to trust me and if you believe
that my empathy is directed towards you
you are far more likely to trust me when
all three of these things are working
we have great trust but if any one of
these three gets shaky if any one of
these three wobbles Trust is threatened
now here's what I'd like to do I want
each of us to be able to engender more
trust tomorrow
literally tomorrow than we do today and
the way to do that is to understand
where trust wobbles for ourselves and
have a ready-made prescription to
overcome it so that's what I would like
to do together would you give me some
sense of whether or not you're here
voluntarily
yeah okay all right awesome okay so it's
just super helpful feedback so the most
common wobble is empathy
the most common level is that people
just don't believe that were mostly in
it for them and they they believe that
were too self distracted and it's no
wonder we are all so busy with so many
demands on our time it's easy to crowd
out the time and space that empathy
requires for Dylan to be Dylan that
takes real time and for us if we have
too much to do we may not have that time
but that puts us into a vicious cycle
because without revealing empathy it
makes everything harder without the
benefit of the doubt of trust makes
everything harder and then we have less
and less time for empathy and so it goes
so here's the prescription identify
where when and to whom you are likely to
offer your distraction that should trace
pretty perfectly to when where and to
whom you are likely to withhold your
empathy and if in those instances we can
come up with a trigger that gets us to
look up look at the people right in
front of us listen to them deeply
immerse ourselves in their perspectives
then we have a chance of having a sturdy
leg of empathy and if you do nothing
else please put away your cell phone it
is the largest distraction magnet yet to
be made and it is super difficult to
create empathy and Trust in its presence
that takes care of the empathy wobblers
logic wobbles can come in two forms
it's either the quality of your logic or
it's your ability to communicate the
logic now if the quality of your logic
is at risk I can't really help you with
that it's like not in this much time but
fortunately it's often the case that our
logic is sound but it's the it's our
ability to communicate the logic that is
in jeopardy
super fortunately there's a very easy
fix to this if we consider that there
are two ways to communicate in the world
and Harvard Business School professors
are known by two-by-twos nonsense it's
the triangle that rocks if we consider
that there are two ways to communicate
in the world and the first one is when
you take us on a journey a magnificent
journey that has twists and turns and
mystery and drama until you altima t get
to the point and some of the best
communicators in the world communicate
just like this but if you have a logic
wobble this can be super dangerous so
instead I implore you start with your
point in a crisp half sentence and then
give your supporting evidence this means
that people will able to get access to
our awesome ideas and just as
importantly if you get cut off before
you're done ladies
if you get cut off before you're done
you still get credit for the idea as
opposed to someone else coming in and
snatching it from you you just gave me
goosebumps
the third wobble is authenticity and I
find it to be the most vexing we as a
human species can smith out in a moment
literally in a moment whether or not
someone is being their authentic true
self so in many ways the prescription is
clear you don't want to have an
authenticity will be you great and that
is super easy to do when you're around
people who are like you but if you
represent any sort of difference the
prescription to be you can be super
challenging I have been tempted at every
step of my career tempted personally and
tempted by coaching of others to mute
Who I am in the world I'm a woman of
super strong opinions with really deep
convictions direct speech I have a
magnificent life and together we have
such crazy ambition I prefer men's
clothes and comfortable shoes
thank you all birds
in some contexts this makes me different
I hope that each person here has the
beautiful luxury of representing
difference in some context in your life
but with that privilege comes a very
sincere temptation to hold back who we
are and if we hold back who we are we're
less likely to be trusted and if we're
less likely to be trusted we're less
likely to be given stretch assignments
and without those stretch assignments
were less likely to get promoted and so
on and so on until we are super
depressed by the demographic tendencies
of our senior leadership and it all
comes back to our being our authentic
selves so here's my advice wear whatever
makes you feel fabulous pay less
attention to what you think people want
to hear from you and far more attention
to what your authentic awesome self
needs to say and to the leaders in the
room it is your obligation to set the
conditions that not only makes it safe
for us to be authentic but makes it
welcome makes it celebrated cherishes it
for exactly what it is which it is the
key for us achieving greater excellence
than we have ever known as possible so
let's go back to over what happened at
uber when I got there uber was wobbling
all over the place
empathy logic authenticity were all
wobbling like crazy but we were able to
find super effective super quick fixes
for two of the wobbles I'll give you an
illustration of empathy in the meetings
at uber it was not uncommon for people
to be texting one another about the
meeting
I had never seen anything like it it may
have done many things but it did not
create a safe empathetic environment the
solution though super clear technology
often away and that forced people to
look up to look at the people in front
front of them to listen to them to
immerse themselves in their perspectives
and to collaborate in unprecedented ways
logic was equally wobbly and this was
because of the hyper growth of the
organization meant that people managers
were getting promoted again and again
and again soon they were put in
positions that they had no business
being in their physicians outstripped
their capability and it was not their
fault
the solution a massive influx of
executive education that focused
specifically on logic on strategy and
leadership gave people the rigor of the
quality of their logic and it turned a
whole lot of triangles right-side up so
people were able to communicate
effectively with one another the last
one authenticity I'll say it's still
mighty wobbly but honestly that doesn't
make over very different from all of the
other companies I've seen in Silicon
Valley and beyond it is still much
easier to coach people to fit in it is
still much easier to reward people when
they say something that you were going
to say as opposed to rewarding people
when they say something entirely
different than what you are going to say
but when we figure out this when we
figure out how to celebrate difference
and how to let people bring the best
version of themselves forward well holy
cow is that the world I want my son's to
grow up in and with the collection of
people here it would be a privilege to
lock arms with you
and go ahead and rebuild trust in every
corner of the globe thank you very much